- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is stay open.
Over to you, Queen Latifah.
(rooster cawing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entpresso keep me going
- You've won a Grammy, you've
got nominations for an Oscar,
you've won a SAG award,
you've won a Golden Globe,
but you've done so much.
How do you keep going?
What inspires you?
- Honestly, I pray always to stay open.
You know, if you're always
learning something new,
then, you can be inspired.
But I don't just kind of
sit and look at the past,
like I did this, until
people like you remind me
of a lot of stuff, I don't really
think about it in the same way.
Because I see the new
things on the horizon and
I don't feel like I have
to do the same thing
over and over.
I think if you're a creative person, then
you kind of just have to follow your vibe.
If an opportunity is there
for something interesting
that kind of sparks that thing in you,
then you go for it.
And I'm just kind of never
one of those people who
felt like I couldn't do it.
I've got the right people
around me that I believe
to do anything I put my mind to.
- Well you do kind of master
everything that you've done.
- I don't master it all, but
I persevere through it all
and it gives me a chance to
find the next thing to work on.
So, I'm a fighter.
I know how to take them as
much as I can give them.
So that's what we do.
- So I think it's really
important for entrepreneurs
that we stay really focused and stubborn
on our one word, our
values, and the mission
and what we're trying to accomplish.
What we will not tolerate in our life,
but be open to everything else.
I think this is where people fall down.
I think people are too attached to the how
and not enough attached to the why.
So let me explain.
You want to start a
business, you want a ticket
to some big heights, right.
I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs with my business.
I want to do it through Believe.
Those two things are non-negotiable.
I want to have a big impact.
I want to do something that
has the potential to help
a billion entrepreneurs.
And I'm going to do it through Believe.
It's my one word, it's the
most important core value
that I have.
I'm not going to do it in a
way that puts people down.
The goal is not that important
that I would trash people
or throw stones at people
or make people look bad,
to achieve my goal.
That would actually be easier.
If this was a negative
channel, if this was
the 10 biggest failures
of all these people,
if these are the 10 stupid
things that this person did,
I would get a lot more views.
Because in general, people
would rather laugh at somebody,
than try to build them up.
Because we want to just
escape our own life,
and seeing how other
people have had failure,
and how crappy their life is,
it makes us feel better about ourselves.
That's not what I want to build.
Believe is too important to me.
Those two things are non-negotiable.
Big impact, a billion
entrepreneurs through Believe.
Everything else is open.
Right now it's through the book,
it's through my website,
it's through social media,
it's through my YouTube channel.
Those are the main areas
that I'm focusing my time on.
If YouTube stops allowing
me to have the impact
that I'm looking for,
I'll move somewhere else.
I'll stop doing the channel.
If I can get way more impact
through Believe, writing books,
maybe that's where I start
focusing my attention.
And I think too many of
you are focused to the how.
Not stubborn and focused enough on the why
and what the big thing is.
And too focused on the how.
Well recognize that your how will change.
If you look at the story of
any successful entrepreneur,
you'll see that the how changed.
The plan that they started with,
is never the plan that gets you to where
you end up having your ultimate goal.
It always changes.
That's not to say don't
plan, plan is important.
It's not just go out and see what works.
You have to have a plan.
But understand that the
plan is going to change.
And if you are not open, and you're stuck
and only having it
happen through this plan,
you're likely going to fail.
This is especially an issue,
when you start bringing
people on under you.
My goal, with the people on my team,
is I want to help a billion entrepreneurs
and we're going to do it
through the value of belief.
Give me ideas.
How do we get there?
Let me unlock your talents, your genius,
your creativity, to help me get there.
Let's do this together.
Because if all you're going
to do is exactly what I
tell you to do, we're always
going to be restricted.
You know, and I learned this
lesson in my first business
where I spent too much
time planning and planning,
and planning and planning.
And I lost out on a huge
deal because I over planned.
I think a lot of us get stuck on the how
because we've invested
time, energy, effort, money
into one path.
Which may ultimately
not be the path, right.
I've bought lights and
I've got a camera man
and I've got editors and
I've got this team around
building a YouTube channel.
It'd be hard to walk away from.
Especially when other people's
jobs are on the line as well.
But if it's not helping me accomplish
what I want to accomplish,
then I have to do it.
I have to make that
tough decision to go off
and do something else.
Now, don't freak out.
I'm not going anywhere,
YouTube is a great platform,
I love it and this is amazing.
I look forward to my filming
days and all you guys
in the comments.
But, if it came to that,
I might have to switch
to something else.
In my original plan,
YouTube wasn't part of it.
I never wanted to be YouTube famous.
It was through my website
that all these things
were going to happen.
And I adjusted because
I was getting a lot more
awareness, a lot more
attraction, a lot more fun
through the YouTube channel.
And that may change again
in a year, two years,
five years, 20 years or never.
Stubbornness around the why,
stubbornness around
your one word core value
and complete flexibility
and openness around
everything else.
That's the key.
So the question today is I'm curious,
what are the non-negotiables for you?
What's the why for you?
What's the big thing
you're trying to build
and what's your one word core value?
Put it in the comment's below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Brenda and Bill Schreiner.
Thank you guys so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
it really means a lot to me.
I hope you're learning
some good lessons that
you're applying to your
business and to your life,
and I appreciate the support.
Thank you guys again for watching,
I hope you have an amazing day!
I believe in you and hope you continue to
believe in yourself!
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entpresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entpresso keep me going
- I think to secret to my career is
I don't know what I can't do
(interviewer laughs)
There are times when I should probably sit
and think do I really want
to jump out there with
Philip Seymour, I mean
with John C. Reilly,
and sing The Night Chicago Died
or do I really want to play
the blues with Little Ed.
You know, you just do it.
You just do these things.
- [Interviewer] And you become,
the audience wants you to do these things.
- Yes, I think what's,
I don't know what it is,
but I think over the years,
people have gotten comfortable
with the notion that
I try things.
- [Interviewer] It's almost puntinesque
- And they're not worried about me.
Do you know what I mean?
I think that's the key.
People aren't worried
about me getting hurt
because,
I can, you know, I'll
give it a hundred percent
and then if it completely
falls on it's face,
I'll laugh about it an move on.
And I think there's a little bit of sense
after all these years,
people say, you know
all right he tried it.
Maybe it worked, maybe it didn't work,
but he had a good time.
- And for you, you can
come back the next night
and the next night and the next night.
- Yeah, I mean that's,
you know, I don't know.
There's a,
Over the years I've realized
that there are a lot of
comedians that are very worried
about keeping their dignity in tact.
And keeping their personal space and
keeping their sense of authority.
And for better or worse,
and it might be worse,
I don't have that.
You know what I mean?
The people that I've
always liked growing up,
and I'm not just talking
about late night comedians.
I'm talking about anybody
in movie, in film.
The people I liked, Peter Sellers, they
- Would let it all hang out.
- Be just go, you know.
If you look at a lot of those
old classic Carson clips,
he's jumping into hot
tubs with Don Rickles,
he's jumping through fake
walls, he's falling on his ass
he's dressed as Floyd Turbo.
And so sometimes I look back
to that and I remembered
well, Johnny just went for it,
So for better or worse, I'll
try, I'll get out there.
I'm very physical and my
wife is always horrified.
I'm always coming out of
the shower just covered
in bruises and she'll say what was that?
And I'll say, Oh, I did a bit,
we had Jeff Garlin on
the show and he and I
rolled down a flight of steps
and I hit a fire hydrant.
- And I achieved the goals I wanted
in the Karate world, in the
world title and my schools.
And I was trying to
decide what new energies,
where I wanted to direct
my energies at and
Steve McQueen, who was one of my students,
at the time, suggested the acting field.
And I just had finished
a movie with Bruce Lee,
called Return of the Dragon.
So I decided that I would pursue that.
- Have a mind that is open to everything,
and attached to nothing.
One of the central
principles of my life is
that no one knows enough
to be a pessimist,
about anything.
And that each and every one of us,
when we close our mind to
what is possible for us
or what is possible for humanity,
closes off the genius,
that resides and lives
in each and every one of us.
Having an open mind
doesn't necessarily mean
finding fault with all of the things
that you've been taught by others.
It means, opening yourself up
to the potentiality and the possibility
that anything and everything is possible.